made multiple attempts for comments for
weeks from CCSD on this and while
they're remaining relatively quiet right
now the parents and students here feel
shut out over the principle that they
call an icon to this community
we should be finding out how to clone
him and put him as a principal in every
single one of these schools a principal
with an impact he's very Student First
oriented they're talking about Keith
whipperman who spent years in the Clark
County School District most recently as
principal at Centennial High I don't
know why he would have been removed
that's until earlier this month when
students report whipperman was escorted
off campus no explanation given the
rumors have been very disparaging and as
you can imagine damaging to him
personally as well as his family several
other parents rode into eight news now
feeling the same at change.org petition
opposing his removal has reached over 2
200 signatures and yet no email to
parents no message to students a source
sending us this email to High School
staff saying he was given quote other
duties I have fear that there will be a
decision made without any input or
without it even being warranted and then
it will be too late we asked the
district why they said it's a Personnel
matter we are unable to comment at this
time we also asked CCSD trustee Katie
Williams who represents Centennial High
School she said we encourage parents to
wait until all the information comes out
from whatever investigation is going on
answers not sufficient to these parents
if the allegation against him fits the
punishment that's one thing but if it's
not Equitable or fair then that's
another reason to to Rally behind him
now all that the school did confirm to
us is that he was not arrested
whipperman himself did not return our
calls for comment on this and those
parents you just heard from they're
expecting answers tomorrow at the school
board meeting at five o'clock tomorrow
night though it's not listed as an
agenda item they say they will be
pressuring those officials to get them
reporting live outside Centennial High
School Ryan Matthey 8 News Now